okay why I am not in a relationship
because my relationship was toxic I was
getting hurt by somebody that was how do
you attract the same thing wait wait
wait wait wait wait so so it's because
it was toxic why do you attract toxic
men I attracted one okay but you stayed
with him for five years probably because
of daddy issues potentially okay because
my dad was very strong and powerful what
are you because your dad was powerful
very strong and powerful and with that
me having that as a realization
what am I doing to Silver yeah your
daddy issues I've already done it I've
already I analyzed everything I've
already studied myself like a therapist
not for very long I just sit down I
speak to a lot of my guy friends I've
got big brothers that speak to me and
they tell me exactly the things that
should be should and shouldn't be done
being a dumb woman is not a good thing